Tom Waits loved the novel J.T. Leroy had written called Sarah. He wanted to do an
interview with J.T. Leroy for Vanity Fair magazine and he wanted J.T.'s input on who
would photograph the spread because J.T. Leroy was notoriously shy. One of the reasons why
J.T. was so shy was because J.T. didn't have a body. J.T. was an avatar. So let me take you
back some years. I was 16, 17 years old and I was awarded the state in a group home in
New York City. Eight girls, one bathroom. And the girls had all had stories being some had
been raped, stabbed by a parent, sold into slavery. Everyone had secrets. At night time,
we'd tell our secrets and you couldn't tell. And I was the one they would come to and tell
their stories. And if you asked me why I was there, I don't know. All the intakes,
dysfunctional family, I dropped out of school, I don't know. But I was always interested in
how do you tell? And there was this movie, Streetwise, it was a documentary by Mariel and Mark
about homeless kids in Seattle. And I gathered up some of my friends, my best friend Lauren from
the group home. We'd been institutionalized together prior to the group home. And we went
and saw this movie. And we saw ourselves on the screen. Now the street can seduce you. And these
kids were getting swallowed. And we knew we were just one step removed. And when we left the movie,
I saw how people looked at us right before they were kind of scared of us. And I got off on that,
you know, because we'd street all over us. But after the movie, they looked at us with this kind
of curious compassion. And suddenly, I didn't want to be the victim in the movie. I was interested
in how do you make that bridge so people suddenly care and curious enough to maybe
care? How do you do that? And in the group home, everyone's telling their stories. And I don't even
know how to tell mine. I don't even have the tools to tell mine. And I would go to buy a little relief
to a street corner. There's a phone booth right on the corner. And I would remove it from me. I'd be
a boy. And I'd call hotlines. And I'd tell them all the stories, my story, my pain, everyone's
stories, the houseparent who survived the Biafran Wars, and say to me, Laura, your job is to tell
our stories. Because in the group home, my job was I was the translator. So some girls having some
problems with the houseparent, they'd come to me and I would translate between what each other was
saying. Again, if you asked me, I don't know. All I knew is if you heard what my story was,
my deepest belief was that you would say, well, you deserve it. You're disgusting. You're horrible.
My deepest hope was that you wouldn't. But I never ever gave you the chance. But I wanted to learn the
tools to tell because that's the bridge. And I won a scholarship to the New School for Social Research.
And they let me in without the SATs. I said, I can't take the SATs. My last grade of completion is
six. And they let me in with an essay. I'm taking every writing class I can get my hands on. And I
wrote this piece in this class about, you can tell a kid that's not going to survive long on the street
because the scars run this way. And the kids are there wrapped in wrapped, you know. And everyone's
looking to see whose exterior matches the story. And everyone's looking at this one cool guy. He's
all raggedy. And I'm in the group home. And I'm just looking. I'm looking at him too. And I want it to be
him because he matches the voice. And I don't want them to know it's me because it's going to ruin it.
I want it to be him. And then when they leave, because they don't know it was anonymous reading
the story. And then when we leave, I hear people talking about, wow, I never thought of it that way.
I didn't know that about the scene. And I'm like, that's what I want. How do you get people to see
what they never saw before? They never knew before. I keep writing, but never as myself. The writing
gives me a little more relief. I start writing under the name Jeremy, which becomes JT. For me,
I buy myself another day every time I can find a way to tell, but as long
as it's not coming from me, never as a woman. So when I get asked by Tom Waits,
when he asked JT Leroy who he wants to photograph, Mary Ellen Mark, my sister-in-law came over one day
and she just shaved her head. And I'm looking at her and she looks like the blonde hair, blue-eyed
little boys that I would see in the after school specials when they were just starting to talk
about abuse, sexual abuse. Always a blonde hair, blue-eyed cute little boy that you would forgive
and love no matter what they did, no matter how transgressive and bad they were. You just love them.
I never saw myself represented in any of that. So she looked. She was JT. And she agreed to be my
avatar. Now, Mary Ellen Mark said that the person she was photographing did not feel like somebody
who had suffered, like someone. It felt like someone who maybe came from privilege, but she said the
books needed to be in the world, that the book showed a world she had never seen, that she wanted
the books to be out there. And she photographed the avatar. I continued to publish under the name JT
Leroy. I wrote the book Sarah, which was received with great acclaim. I published it as fiction,
all my work as fiction. Came to pass that this book that explored the wilds of West Virginia,
a state I had never been in, in this kind of magical, I play with gender and identity and
it's the spirit, everything that I had experienced, all the pain, all the suffering, the joy, the hope,
holding on to finding that a possibility of being saved no matter what, the spirit,
the humor, it was all in there turned upside down. In this book, Sarah came to pass that I am revealed
as JT Leroy. The articulation in the New York Times is hoax, perpetrator, culprit, the jig is up,
come clean, liar, fake fiction writer. No, New York Times, fake fiction writer.
Oscar Wilde said, give a man a mask and he'll tell you the truth.
I received death threats, hate mail, was blacklisted, sued in federal f*****g court.
People didn't understand why I wouldn't apologize. She won't apologize. I wouldn't,
how could you apologize for what kept, it kept me alive? I couldn't do it. I couldn't do it.
It kept me alive. I couldn't do it another way. I knew no other way.
Slowly the fan mail came back. I would get letters where people would talk about what the work meant
to it, how it transformed them, how it saved their lives, how it allowed them to see a world
that they had never seen before. I got invited to speak, welcome back into the community of artists,
to speak all over the world. In spring, I did a sold out reading at Foyles in London
and I'm signing books as me
and these collectors are there and, you know, I'm signing books where, editions in languages
that I didn't even know existed and sign this, sign this, sign this and I'm leaving my body
and all of a sudden the crowds kind of part
and this girl comes walking towards me. She's big and she's got cuts all over her arms.
She's carrying a bag and I know what's coming. It's what I've been preparing for my whole life.
She reaches in her bag and I know she's going to stab me
and she takes out a book and she tells me that she came to my work after the reveal.
She asks me to sign her diary.
I realize that everything that had happened up to that moment had prepared me for this
and I got up
and I held her.
Thank you.